we've seen it plenty of times over the
years where someone comes in and takes
the nfl by storm in his first year as a
starter and then opposing defenses have
an entire offseason to break down every
little nook and cranny of his game to
come up with ways to take steam out of
what was a great performance the year
before and for patrick mahomes 50
touchdown passes league mvp almost took
the chiefs to the super bowl will he
have a sophomore slump in 2019 induced
by defenses that figure out how to slow
the chiefs down and you can see little
bits and pieces of where that challenge
may come from because we've heard
mahomes talk about having a willingness
to take what a defense is giving him to
take what's open underneath because i
think what we're going to see defenses
do they are going to drop into that
shell like the patriots did in the afc
championship game keep everything in
front of them put extra help all the
time on covering receiver tyreek hill
who good news for the chiefs will be
available this year bad news for those
opposing defenses but if patrick mahomes
gets frustrated and try to tries to
force the ball down the field to make a
spectacular play and the defenses are
taking away those plays that becomes the
kind of thing that makes it harder to
duplicate what we saw last year you know
the beauty of the chief's offense it
forces defenses to cover every blade of
grass on the field if they focus more on
those blades of grass that are deep on
the field will the chiefs and more
specifically will my mahomes be willing
to take what's there dink and dunk if
need be and can he sustain drives with
dink and dunk type plays instead of
those spectacular moments that
characterized his entire season as the
first year starter for the kansas city
chiefs chances are that the kind of
greatness we saw from the homes last
year is going to translate to year in
and year out greatness but it's one of
the big questions going in to 2019
because what he did in 2018 was so
special just merely expecting him to do
the same thing
is a tall order we all kind of think
there's going to be a little bit of a
dip but who knows maybe mahomes goes
back to the lab and he comes back after
working with coach andy reid better than
he was in 2019 and if that's the case
get ready for the chiefs to be playing
in and winning plenty of super bowls
over the next 15 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports